hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from the 2005 MTEL masters between
Veselin Topalov and Ruslan ponomaryov
this game acts as a very good example of
an attacking play as can be seen with
just the final score sheet the game
lasting only 30 moves in we really do
get to see very sharp play very quickly
in this game so to Paula on the white
end opening up with d4 for tomorrow
night f6 after c4 e6 we're going with a
Queen's Indian this b6 looking for Queen
side fiend kettle white doing similar
for their King side Bishop and now
Bishop to a6 targeting c4 since this
Bishop is now looking forward to being
deployed to g2 it's not going to be
there too conveniently watch over this
c4 square so white conveniently defends
at b3 I say convenient because not only
is it defending the pawn but maybe the
bishop wants to now make use of this
diagonal so I don't know if it's really
that much of an inconvenience but we
have Bishop b4 at this point Bishop d2
to block and then the bishop goes back
so the quick summary with these two
pivots right here this check is just
thrown in because this black is wanting
that bishop to be placed on d2 rather
than its home square this bishop is a
bit awkwardly placed on d2 if it really
does want to get on this main diagonal
I'd have to go to c3 where it's
certainly going to be more accessible to
the black pieces namely a night landing
on even on that e4 square so after the
bishop goes back we have more
development on the white end Knight c3
black castles enriches c1 I'm not sure
what the big difference is between the
two right here I mean like there's rook
c1 there's there's probably four there's
bishop - G - I think rook to c1 is
taking into account that there might be
quick pressure being placed on this c4
Square and so this rook is just getting
in position to watch over it in fact
white at this point can already be
anticipating a black pawn being places
that d5 square and in the event that
that is played y could just capture and
then there you go you have a half-open
file for that rook so certainly a
purposeful Square for that piece and
black is just going to follow up now
with c6 preparing this d5 advance after
E for d5 we have E 5 a great change has
just occurred in the pawn structure and
with this white pun on the e5 square
that right there can already be the
beginning of an attack against the black
king because it's very worthwhile to
take note of the following just
generally speaking in a game of chess a
king night on the f3 f3 square + f6
square will often act as excellent
defenders of your own King side and so
not having that square available for
that night might subject you to an
attack and that's exactly what we see in
a very very direct way in this
particular game so we have 94
centralizing the knight but it really
cannot be maintained white puts
immediate pressure on it with their
Bishop which is a little bit maybe
awkward looking because you do this
g3 move with the intention of playing
Bishop to g2 but certainly you have to
take into account the specifics of the
position and right now I black is just
placing their knight on that efore
square a-square that's in your territory
on your four ranks of the chess board
let's say and so taking immediate action
and putting a question to that piece
certainly makes sense and so
additionally this Bishop is now pointing
down at the h7 Square and we'll see how
purposeful this turns out to be so the
knight has to give itself up i takes on
c3 rook takes and now c5 there's a
couple of reasons maybe behind this
particular advance one striking at the
center - its vacating c6 for that Knight
and three well I think I said to
initially put there's there's many many
reasons here the bishop can always maybe
go back to this b7 Square and try and
take over this corner to corner diagonal
that main diagonal right there seeing
now that this bishop has decided to go
elsewhere and focus on the h7 Square
so after this c5 advance we have white
just taking on c5 first I think one of
the reasons for that is because white
really is not wanting to have their
knight have have to recapture on that
square
it would just be accessible to let's say
that black Queen at some point you know
like if just castle or something could
have takes takes takes and then before
you know if this Knight is in trouble so
just getting out of any of that sort of
nonsense white just takes on c5 after
the recapture we don't have routine like
play at this point
so forget about the natural well we have
an open position in open position we
need to get our king's castle now now in
this game we have h4 of all things so
certainly a very aggressive move this
rook is actually already contributing to
this position in a great way and natural
developing moves like let's say Knight
to c6 are punished immediately with
moves like Bishop takes King takes
Knight g5 if the King goes back we have
Queen h5 looking for made on h7 this is
Greek gift sacrifice you know that that
Bishop takes on h7 type of move slightly
along those lines certainly with the
sacrifice on h7 and the night playing to
g5 allowing for the Queen's clearance to
that h5 square so with the main threat
on that h7 squared there really isn't
anything convenient you could take out
the knight but there we go the rook
finally comes to life and there is no
running way because this pawn puts a
stop to that flight Square for the King
mate will ensue on h8 so there's that's
this is the main threat with this with
this H pawns advanced this is preventing
knight c6 and so seeing that black plays
h6 and so when you move upon in front of
your King if you move upon off of a
light Square that implies your light
squares are weakened in some sense and
so white is taking action by playing
Bishop to b1 looking for a battery along
this b1 to h7 diagonal so sensing danger
here this is where
black feels it necessary to press
forward with their f-pawn looking for
maybe some lateral defense
maybe the rook bumping up and maybe just
trying to shut down this diagonal hull
together
but light will not have any of that
instead just captures about f6 square
after the recapture the bishop is
hitting the rook but it doesn't matter
to polyp does not care about this rook
right now the idea here is going to be
to try and chase this King away and go
for some sort of an attack at this point
we see d4 but just running quickly with
what would happen exactly or at least
one thing that can happen we could have
the Queen giving check after the King
runs out we could just have Bishop takes
Bishop here and with moves of Bishop
takes pawn Queen takes pawn Knight e5
it's hard to say that there's going to
be a save on the black end here
certainly there's a lot of aggressive
white pieces both bishops a knight a
queen and these guys over here are not
doing anything great so we don't have
Bishop takes rook but instead d4 so now
it's the pawn that's attacking the rook
but it's completely ignored Knight g5
looking for mate again on h7 a wonderful
move certainly and after it's actually
captured now we have the recapture and
now we have this real calm coming to
life right here all the white pieces are
contributing in some way well I guess
this rook not so much I really don't see
it coming over laterally but it's
actually turning out to be an expendable
piece and we see not only the knight
falling on that g5 square but soon
enough this rook to falls upon takes
rook and now Bishop to f4 before you
know it this game is going to be
finished up we're actually just 10 moves
away white is down a rook and a knight
but certainly has very aggressive pieces
all the pieces that White has right now
are functioning in a great way again my
I cannot help but just gravitate towards
the Queen side those guys are doing
nothing and what it is soon coming down
to is a great difference between
attacking pieces versus defensive pieces
and we're going to see that shortly
right here so the King decides to just
make way and start to run one thing to
be aware of and this would just be just
throwing this quick example out this is
this wood right here would be an example
of a help me rook to f2 wood f7 really
doesn't have any meaning it's just
allowing light to come up with a matin -
this is just a neat little sacrifice to
lure that King to that corner square and
deliver me but that didn't happen in the
game just something to be aware of a
nice little tactic instead we have king
f7 after Queen check King e7 all these
moves right here essentially being
forced upon takes Bishop check rook
takes is forced otherwise pawn takes
we're going to have this and that's
leading to mate in one on the next turn
so that's why we're having rook takes
Queen takes pawn check if the King goes
back we're going to have the rook
playing to that ah8 square delivering
mate soon enough rook black Bishop check
looking to get that Queen Queen takes
rook Queen takes bishop and now a nice
quiet move right here running all the
calculations we have rip to h7 looking
for mate on c7 and fortunately there is
well unfortunately for black there is no
save at this point there is no perpetual
check if something like this is tried
well they could only be going on for so
long there is no more successful check
and soon enough that King is going to be
dead there's just one last thing that
white is essentially needing to watch
out for at this point after Queen e5
check King F 1 black plays to the c6
square and it may be very tempting to
try and do something like Bishop to e4
giving check however this King might get
it get the crazy idea or in fact a good
idea to start running along these dark
squares and this attack and all of a
sudden just go nowhere so some precision
is just needed in this final stage of
the game and it finishes up very nicely
a couple accurate checks starting with
Queenie 8 king b6 Queen da King
see six and only after this square has
been controlled do we now see Bishop to
e4 which is going to be leading to mate
very quickly if Queen takes bishop the
game would fund finish up very nicely
with Queen to c7 and that's me but as it
was in this game after Bishop to e4
black ends up resigning so that's all
for this video as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye